one marry a girl for like status in that
way well that is one of the most I mean
if you look at arranged marriages his
office status right that's an example
but men men primarily married for I I'd
argue that men and I say this about men
but women do the same thing right women
love the idea of getting status from a
man women love the idea and this is
where it actually gets a bit messy the
waters get muddy because women love the
idea of bragging about the man they're
with but they can only brag about the
man they're with if other women want
that man so you're saying you love women
who get cheated women love getting
cheated on that's not true but women do
not like men other women don't want if
you were to say look I got my man he's
perfect he's rich and every girl in the
room would go I would never touch him
she was like oh [ __ ] well I don't want
him either then what the [ __ ] you know
so but but it's true right women want
women want men that that all the women
want do you know what's the best man
that woman wants is the one that every
girl wants paid doesn't want them a
selective man I'm sure that's more
valuable than the topics
and women should accept that that's the
problem men are continuously
disrespecting their woman like yeah you
know what you want you can't be with one
woman now you want to keep cheating with
all these different that's not what he
said you know he's saying if you're
gonna go if you're gonna go for a high
status guy if you're gonna go for the
top five percent of guys that's what
comes with it and if you're not then go
for the average guy can I just say that
that before is it okay for average guys
to stick with one woman then it's not
about okay it's okay for anyone to do
whatever they want I'm not sitting here
saying what's okay and what isn't okay
what I'm talking about is observations
about the Baseline realities of how
humans function what I'm telling is if
you give a man unlimited options like
the men at the top of society have on a
long enough time scale he will explore
said options that is a fact like I said
earlier you can walk into a car garage
and buy a Nissan and that's reliable and
I'll never let you down or you can buy a
McLaren you cannot sit like women do and
go I want the McLaren that's reliable
like in this sand well guess [ __ ] one
that's not real so you have to choose
something years ago right do you do you
think it makes a difference because
years ago if you want to meet a man you
go out there you actually talk but now
you meet a guy you can go and check out
your ID and see what you're all about
can't don't you think that by them being
able to look and see what you're all
about that makes a difference to how
they perceive you 100 I think Society is
fundamentally and utterly broken I think
the way that men and women interact is
broken I think that men are broken I
think that women are broken I think
everything is completely [ __ ]
genuinely and and this is where we go
into the small things we're talking
about status you're right about IG if I
go on a date with a girl and I look at
her Instagram page I'm sitting there
thinking does this make me look good or
bad yes I want her to be hot yes I want
her to have followers yes I want
everyone chasing her but what's that
caption about about [ __ ] City Life
what's this about what's that that's not
that's not nah that puts me off right so
it's interesting what's also interesting
is the majority of women don't have a
clue in the modern world what men find
attractive so we said earlier in the
very beginning of this podcast about men
who want their dick sucked that's
[ __ ] men don't that's not attractive
to men we don't want any of that most
women if you were to say how do you
attract a man they wouldn't have a
Scooby-Doo they wouldn't have an idea I
know they want a submissive woman hello
give him some songs
[Music]
it's not just about that the the one of
the one of the important things for
being a man especially in a relationship
is we want to be our woman if I have a
woman and I love her I want to be her
portal to the world I want her to
experience things through me and see
things through me so for that I need a
degree of innocence and superiority for
her I want to be the first person to put
her on a private jet I want her to get
on the Jet and go wow I did it oh you
took me it's like giving you wouldn't
want to give someone a Christmas present
if they'd had 10 presents better than
you beforehand yeah it's like well so as
a man so as a woman what makes you
attractive to a man to a degree is your
innocence and your Purity this is very
important and it can go down to very
basic simple things I'll tell you if I
walk in a club do you know who the
hottest girl in the club it's the girl
who isn't dancing isn't twerking on a
[ __ ] dead stage not surrounded by
dude girls when girls want male
attention in a club they start drinking
twerking that is the most revolting
Haram [ __ ] I may want to [ __ ] you
but I don't want to be with you if you
show me a girl sitting in the corner shy
I'm like good she hasn't experienced too
much life I can show her things and also
not just show her things this is a very
important point that I get attacked by
The Matrix Forks they completely
misunderstand me on purpose
as a man if I'm out here struggling and
leading and trying to leave my household
I also want a woman who shares my values
I want to a degree to educate my woman
and show her things and for her to agree
with me like you said earlier looking
for a male role model you want to be a
role model to your woman if she's too
experienced with life it's difficult to
be a role model if she's sitting there
shy and quiet you can come along and say
no you know what don't take the [ __ ]
vaccine listen to me and you can be a
role model for her you can't do that for
a woman who knows too [ __ ] much knows
too many dudes been too many places so
it's his degree of Purity that we're
looking for that's super important
I'm curious if you said if she's like
done too many things that's like bad
right that's correct so not I'm not even
talking sexually like that on a private
jet I'm curious because I live just how
do you get on a private jet without
sucking dick oh I was just curious
because my my dad's part of like he's
top like one percent in terms of like
income and I was just curious is it
different if you did stuff with your dad
well no that's fine
yeah but no but my point is that we're
looking for a true degree of Innocence
inside of females and it's that
innocence that's going to make us feel
protective over them and that the
protectiveness is going to make us be
good men so so when we're looking at
society as a whole and how broken it is
I understand that men have a massive
role to play we don't have a massive
role to play but a lot of the paternal
instincts and instinctual behaviors of
men because the instinctual behavior of
man is to die for his woman like someone
comes to try and take her pull a sword
die to defend her right if you're if
you're going through life and you find
that men don't really feel about you
that way that's because a lot of their
instinct is being eroded by the fact
that you like you said they look for
your IG or they look for your life and
you've lived so much life and they just
feel like there's nothing new I can
bring to this girl's reality I don't
feel like that's true though because
like I think it's like I get what you're
saying to a degree right but it's like
you you could be on a private jet 10
times but it's going to be special
because it's with you not for him it
isn't not for him for him it's special
because it's your first time because men
maybe it's a biological predisposition
maybe it's just the way we're designed
but let's let's tie it back to sex
virginity first time it's not that
you've done it so you've done it with
the first time with me that's what is
important it's experience as a whole
that men find it's just the truth call
me misogynistic cancel me whatever I'm
telling the truth I always have done
it's experience of Life as a whole that
men to a degree find off-putting we
don't want a woman who's had a bunch of
trauma had a bunch of experiences done a
bunch of [ __ ] knows a bunch of people
been a bunch of places that's the
absolute opposite of what we want we
want the complete polar opposite of that
and what's funny is women want men who
have who have done those things I'll
tell you right now go out there and find
a virgin woman and say do you want to
have your first boyfriend do you want to
lose your virginity to a virgin man or a
man or a man who who's had a couple
girls she'll choose a dude with
appearance as a virgin herself
experiences is always commented and
respected in men it's the opposite in
women so it's true so we have to look at
how [ __ ] up the world is women
especially in there between their 18 and
28 or 18 and 25 let's say are living
these crazy Lifestyles these crazy lives
with the most important people richest
people on the planet doing everything
that can be experienced Under the Sun
and then at 29 30 some dudes expected to
come along know he's second place to XYZ
and be happy with that and and and and
and and and not not allow it to hurt his
ego and and sit there and pick it up and
put a [ __ ] Brave face on it kills him
every day inside that's the reality he's
in love with you and you've been [ __ ]
where with [ __ ] who I got afford a
jet I'm Joe schmoe that [ __ ] breaks
their hearts do you do you think that
hoes can never be turned into Housewives
okay I'll answer that question and the
answer is actually truthfully yes
which I know a lot of people are
confused to buy they can if you're a
good enough high enough level man you
absolutely can turn a hoe into a
housewife but why the [ __ ] would you
because you don't have to a man like me
I could but I don't I don't have I'm not
low odd option so I would never decide
to do that if you're a billionaire could
you you know you can find an old rusty
car and rebuild it or you can just buy a
new one right so it's not that it's not
about what could be done it's about what
will be done so once women here certain
state is a man I don't think women are
stupid I actually argue the fact that
women have a beautiful intuition I think
that women to a degree their intuition
is truly almost psychic the number of
girls number of times I've come home and
she's like you're cheating and I was
like how the [ __ ] [ __ ] chick do you
have intuition and it's real you guys
are you guys are smart right and if they
get to a certain Echelon of man they're
not going to go anywhere because there's
nowhere else to go they're gonna get to
a guy eventually they're going to stop
at the buck and go you know what
where am I going to surpass this
specimen so I'm just going to behave for
him so you could turn a hoe into a
housewife that way but why would a man
at that level want to do why why do some
um guys at certain and this is obviously
a celebrity example but I'm sure we can
all think of examples in like day-to-day
life where a guy with a lot of options
does pick a hoe and like wife her like
for example Kim and Kanye
because it kind of clearly has options
she did not want to be a housewife no
she was a project okay I understand I'm
just asking because some guys do pick
yeah they do and it's a really good
point and I have nothing bad to say
about Kanye in fact I think a lot of the
work he's doing now in terms of
attacking the Matrix is is important but
I can give you a generalized answer but
it's a man who is not true to his
masculine imperative which is going to
fall for the propaganda machine which is
being purported upon him who's going to
believe that all the crap that is being
told by Society like a female's past
doesn't matter and all this [ __ ] doesn't
matter this is what's interesting in the
fight against the Matrix because people
always say to me Andrew why do you come
here and say all these things they're
literally trying to destroy your life
for what you say and the truth is as a
man you have two choices you either
fight against a programming in the
brainwashing they're trying to put
inside of all of our minds or you end up
fighting against yourself if you're a
man and you sit down and you believe the
garbage that Society is telling you
about the how Society functions between
men and women you're going to end up
getting [ __ ] wrecked like these dudes
do they sit there and go just because
she's [ __ ] everyone doesn't mean
she'll do it again just because they sit
there are dummies and they get [ __ ]
wrecked right you have to sit there as a
man and go no I don't give a [ __ ] what
Society is telling me I understand
something Baseline about Humanity right
and that's why they make these poor
choices and a lot of men do make these
poor choices but it's only in the west
it's only in the west where this
propaganda machine exists you will not
find a Russian billionaire doing this
dumb [ __ ] you will not find a Chinese
billionaire doing this dumb [ __ ] you do
not go to Saudi and find a shake doing
this dumb [ __ ] none of it you only find
it in the west do you do you think the
values of the West are spreading what
what values
sorry sorry sorry as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible